c'est dans ce sillage celle des que la
dpj des laurentides à d'abord logé des
adolescentes début juin et les jeunes
filles sont restées là deux semaines on
sache sld et depuis le 15 juin elle
réside au deuxième étage d'un hôtel à
blainville deux semaines plus tard la
dpj installe les adolescentes dans cet
hôtel de blainville c'est une entrée
indépendante
notre unité de désengorgement pour dix
jeunes sont en contact avec le reste de
la population de la
qui peuvent avoir un hyper chenal août
est le dixième la nouvelle unité
d'hébergement aménagé à l'hôtel a été
baptisée la transition ont accès à des
locaux pour faire du jeu est en mesure
de déployer l'ensemble de l'offre de
services à thé du personnel et du qatar
les centres existants sont saturés parce
que les signalements sont en hausse
depuis un an 2000 à 13000 quelques
signalements
qui est très important ça veut dire plus
de jeunes à héberger alors qu'on manque
de personnel et parce que le recrutement
est plus difficile dans le nord des
laurentides on déplace les activités au
sud des laurentides ou avoir le
personnel requis c'est vers le sud est
bon bien entendu blainville s'est bien
situé les gens veulent travailler à cet
endroit d'autant qu'on était en mesure
de le staff est assez aisément pour
régler le problème il faut un nouveau
centre jeunesse qui selon le ciss sera
prêt en 2024 voyons dans ses 6 v sur une
autre planète
le projet était près le dossier de
proximité avait été fait on a vendu aux
douces et d'affaires et on devait livrer
le projet en 2023 pourquoi ce qui n'ont
pas lancé le projet c'est la question
que je leur pose et je le dis si tu ils
ont été irresponsables
le cabinet du ministre responsable
lionel carmant qu'on vient du fait que
la situation n'est pas idéale mais
précise que parce que les ressources des
bordes il faut trouver des solutions
même temporaire ici david gêne-t-il
radio-canada bon air